sandy having a terrific season this year
as well 323 coming in up over a hundred
strikeouts and this is 21st start of the
year
and he goes down first strikeout tonight
for sandy two-way and what a change-up
it was for his first strikeout tonight
for the bottom fall out of this marlins
fans my goodness so first and third and
here is sandy leone and now leon this
one hit well out to right what an at-bat
deep and
three-run homer onto utah street for
sandy leone
eighth pitch of the at-bat
watkins had yet to give up a hit with a
runner in scoring position
this season all of it coming to a head
here for sandy leone he saw the entire
arsenal he fought off pitch after pitch
and then he leaned on a curveball a
knuckle curve 80 miles an hour stayed up
had plenty of distance question was fair
or foul there's your answer you see
sandias where the base is full the 1-0
ripped to the right side diving grab on
the line by mount castle to his feet he
underhands it to watkins at the bag out
complete and any over the marlin strand
the bases loaded a tremendous play by
ryan mount castle
right down the right field line
and that got by him it scores at least
two and maybe three
but instead the marlin strand the base
is loading
[Applause]
98 miles an hour second strikeout for
sandy alcatra 0-2 pitch on the way from
sandy
is in there for a call strike three
back-to-back strikeouts and three the
first time through for alcantara well he
had it set up
pretty perfectly and gone at him with
nothing but high 90s fastballs and of
course the changeup at 93 locks him up
starling martay now a chance to drive in
a run 1-1 pitch
and that's a ground ball up the middle
of base hit
sierra on his way to third leone scores
easily an rbi single for starling marte
just snuck through up the middle and
it's four nothing i got to tell you a
little surprise dory has kind of got
burned by this a little earlier in the
ball game in fact when aguilar was
hitting this ball is not hit hard but
because of his defensive positioning
unable to get to the baseball and
because he didn't keep it on the infield
that allows sierra to get all the way
over to third base austin hayes to start
the fourth he's powers one to left field
this is way out of here
a home run for austin hayes
the no hitter the shutout up in smoke
on a long loud swing from austin his
10th home run of the season
well there's the bad changer
the good one swung right through it the
bad ones i mean this ball is really hit
hard felt high middle of the plate
[Applause]
miles per hour
single in a run score fly out to right
field for leiland diaz tonight
and lewin with a drive out to right
field stuart turns he's at the wall and
he runs out of room
a home run for lewin diaz now welcome
back laywin
[Music]
tonight
in the lineup
got the extra hitter for a couple of
games in baltimore and boy oh boy has he
shown up a couple of hits tonight
including this home run through cedric
mullins leading off the orioles six
mullins out to center field this is
pretty well hit marte is back on it at
the wall it is good
he didn't even jump marty
but the ball got chest out of his reach
a home run for cedric mullins and marty
can't believe it is now he hops over the
wall to take a look at what just
happened
well what just happened
is home run number 17 for cedric
well he's happy about it so three pretty
good at bats first time he has something
to show it for him
sandy comes right back strikes out
austin hayes who had homered his last
time up
here's the pitch
swing and a miss and that takes care of
the orioles in the sixth
mount castle striking out two strikeouts
in the inning and five in the game now
for sandy
andy is single is last time up and he
sends this one high and deep out to left
field this will carry homers in
back-to-back games for b.a
a solo homer and the marlins have a 6-2
lead well we started to see the head nod
from b.a a couple of games ago on the
home stand and when you start to see
that smile come back when he's hitting
you know that he's starting to feel
really good in the box
a couple of big swings in the san diego
series going the other way and now the
field really starting to open up for him
very good hitter with runners in scoring
position this year urias
maria's up the middle off the mound into
center field base hit to score a run
it's six to three as ramona rios comes
through again for the runner in scoring
position
well he's the master hitting the ball
back up the middle
every once in a while he'll hit one out
of the ball park
you know hang a slider he'll speed up
the back maybe he'll hit one down the
line
but we showed you in the opening one of
the walk-offs the orioles had what two
maybe three i guess and he has two of
them one of them was against seattle
same type of base hit then game of a
double header
so there is your third run two out base
runner for the marlins here is aguilar
1-2 pitch
is in the left and falling for a base
hit marte around third with two outs off
on the crack at the bat he scores
another rbi for aguilar another run for
the marlins they lead it 7-3 we got a
fastball on the inside part of the plate
just above the knees drove it into left
field and
marta off with the crack at the bat
now 72 extending his lead
exciting time dylan floro into his 43rd
game this year
270 era
or two from floro
and a called strike three gets urias to
start the night now floro setting the
tone for the ninth inning you love it
three pitches
one strikeout most importantly the first
out in this inning
piles up that outside edge
right after
toro gets the strikeout 2k is here in
the ninth
now he is looks fantastic and has all
month of july he's yet to allow an
earned run
11 consecutive scoreless appearances for
flora i mean he's throwing the ball as
well as anybody in that bullpen
i'm not to get lost in all this because
i know there's a fun conversation coming
tonight about the bottom of this lineup
this marlins lineup being so good and
they were
but a strong start from sandy i think
really set the tone floro
comes up when that one flips to first
it's a marlins wins don mattingly and
the marlins go to baltimore for a
two-game series they win the opener
tonight 7-3
[Applause]